ladies and gentlemen get ready to step
up your romance game because kanye west
just took julia fox on a second date and
raised the bar
sky-high
yeah the two recently spent new year's
eve together in miami then jetted off to
new york city on tuesday where they were
snapped attending a broadway play
followed by dinner at italian hot spot
carbone an eyewitness told et that the
two seemed super comfortable with each
other adding quote it doesn't seem like
a new relationship they just seem happy
and at ease around each other but those
paparazzi pics aren't the only evidence
of their romantic date night in true
kanye fashion the whole night was over
the top and included a full on surprise
photo shoot with interview magazine
which the musician arranged i mean we
shouldn't really be surprised remember
when kanye surprised his estranged wife
kim kardashian with kenny g on
valentine's day
or how about that time he rented out a t
park in san francisco to pop the
question to the reality star
[Music]
[Music]
all this to say kanye knows how to make
a moment
i mean it was just fun just do something
for my heart as for the 31 year old
actress she shared a little insight into
how they first met and their big apple
night out telling the mag quote i met
yay in miami on new year's eve and it
was an instant connection julia said
that she and the rapper had such a good
time they quote decided to keep the
energy going and fly back to new york
city to see slave play the two capped
off the night hitting up carbone which
is where the photo shoot took place
quote at the restaurant yay directed an
entire photo shoot for me while people
dined the whole restaurant loved it and
cheered us on while it was happening and
the picks well i'd say they rank pretty
high on the sexy pda meter modeling
clothes cuddling kissing and kissing
some more and after dinner yay brought
her to a hotel room
full of clothes quote it was every
girl's dream come true it felt like a
real cinderella moment i was so
surprised like who does things like this
on a second date or any date it was
really surreal so just how serious are
things between julia and kanye she tells
the mag quote everything with us has
been so organic i don't know where
things are headed but if this is any
indication of the future i'm loving the
ride of course kim filed for divorce
from kanye back in february and has
since been spotted in new york los
angeles palm springs and the bahamas
with saturday night live comedian pete
davidson as for julia according to
reports the actress allegedly revealed
on instagram last month that she's
separated from her husband who was by
her side when etie chatted with her at
the 2019 premiere of her flick uncut
gems you have security with you
i have my husband and he's pretty tough
and russian and scary so no one's coming
close to me the two married in 2018 and
share an 11 month old son and while
sources previously told et that kanye
was trying to repair his marriage to kim
another source now says the data four is
trying to move on kanye has been in good
spirits lately and having fun he's been
spending time with friends going out and
doing his thing he's dating around and
figuring out what he likes in a
potential partner